let's bring in congressman Doug Collins
he's a Republican from Georgia ranking
member of the House Judiciary Committee
US Senate candidate off quarantine for a
week and a half I understand and we are
talking to him live from your house
right right congressman that's right
Annie I'm here this morning bright and
early listening to the good news that
the bill to get passed and that we're
looking forward to getting that relief
sir president Trump's desk that's great
I was reading through some of the things
that are in this bill I don't know if
you've had a chance to read it it's big
and it's coming to your your hands soon
but I read that for small businesses
which is really important that the
package includes 349 billion in loans
and I love this this just shows how
Great America is money spent on rent
payroll or utilities is considered a
grant and those small businesses don't
have to pay it back do you know much
about this yeah that's what we've been
doing our staffs been going over this
bill for the last few days and this
isn't important when we first put this
bill out was about a week or so ago and
we focused on making sure several things
number one our health care was taking
care of our folks and our first
responders were a part of that our state
and local governments and our small
businesses and people that's what the
focus of the president's been that's
what the focus of Republicans been is
making sure we get relief to people so
the number one businesses can keep
people employed we don't want them to
have to feel like they just have to lay
them off and shut their business now we
want to give them the relief that they
needed so if they can keep people
employed keep them off the unemployment
rolls then we can see our economy
comeback quicker and that's what that's
for that's right and you know it cannot
come soon enough
yesterday it was announced that
apparently The Cheesecake Factory that
great big restaurant that everybody
loves to go to they announced through
their CEO apparently yesterday that
apparently they cannot pay their rent
come April 1st and so this particular
bill which the house which you're a
member of Congressman will vote on it
sounds like tomorrow morning it has
passed the Senate here's the Speaker of
the House talking about poison pills and
things like that why if we don't have
unanimous consent my two options with my
members is to call them back to vote for
to amend this bill or to pass our own
bill and then go to conference with them
the easiest way to do it is for us to
come
put aside some of our concerns for
another day and get this done you can
support a bill because if it doesn't do
it enough that you want to do but that's
what you can get but if it has poison
pills in it then and they know certain
things are poison till mm-hm and then
they don't want unanimous consent they
just want an ideological statement so so
congressman that was a couple of days
ago when Nancy Pelosi was talking about
how you would vote on it it sounds like
they would like to do it via unanimous
consent however AOC has already
suggested she might have a problem with
it so it sounds like you're gonna have
to all go back in some fashion to
actually do some voting in person right
well that's what it's looking at right
now there's still a lot of question
about that as far as but it will not be
unanimous again I'll be a voice vote and
then people can have debate people can
go up and actually put it into record or
voice their concerns or how they want to
do it or they can have it put into the
record how they would have voted if they
could have been there we've got some
areas and people cannot attend but it is
sort of interesting over the last few
days for Nancy Pelosi the speaker to
actually talk about putting ideological
pills in there when they tried to put in
the new Green Deal they tried to put in
a lot of different things that we knew
was not gonna be a part of this but they
just knew that this bill was gonna have
to pass so they try to I'm glad to see
she's overcome that at least appear that
this bill will come to the floor so we
can get it to the President's desk right
I mean she's talking about herself
poison pills
she rode into town with two pages of
poison pills and she even got some of
them in this thing so far to say there
was a straight face without a laugh
track is comical meanwhile the big
question is who will Steny Hoyer and
others Kevin McCarthy say I need you men
and women back in Washington or will you
allow to do a voice vote on your phone
or some way as a secure line how do you
see this going yeah we're not gonna be
able to voice oh it over the phone
that's not allowed by our rules the
voice vote will actually occur they'll
call the vote and it'll be a yeah and a
and people will be able to voice that
vote now there'll be a debate time you
can come and be in put a statement in
the record now if someone calls for a
recorded vote then
gonna have to deal with that issue as
well because someone can always call for
a recorded vote which means that every
individual would have to vote on their
own because we do not have the processes
set up right now for proxy vote or for
remote voting and that's something
that's been talked about a lot
especially when you've got members like
in New York and other places who can't
leave from where they are anyway so
again this is gonna be an interesting
time over the next few hours to find out
exactly how they want to do this just to
follow up real quick congressmen on that
view this is not going to be the last
time you're asked to vote you guys got
to come up with a system because there's
gonna be a fourth bill fifth bill and
other things that got to be done but it
might be too dangerous for you to go
back to Washington so you guys got to
come up with something that's better
than the Iowa app we better believe it I
think that's one of the things we've
been talking about a lot there are
things that we can do there's proxy
voting there's also some other ways that
we could actually do this many of us
have been talking about that leader
McCarthy has been very engaged in this I
know the others as well so we need to
look at this as we go forward my hope
though is this after this bill let's
take a pause let's do see what this is
doing just like the 15 days the
president asked for this is now stimulus
it's going to get to the people that
need to get it most our businesses our
people our hospitals then we can see
where we need to go next we don't mean
simply as a Pelosi and schumer want to
just rush into another spending bill we
need to make sure this is working and
targeting just like the president in mr.
secretary minuchin and others have
wanted it and that's what we need to do
first yeah maybe you'll be able to use
ooh more Skype to vote will hopefully be
able to navigate that as we get closer
to the next vote all right let's talk
about a corona virus in your state and
Georgia we're seeing a sudden spike
there 100 I'm sorry 1387 cases forty
seven deaths how storage' doing sir
Georgia's doing as good as we can right
now the governor's taking precautionary
steps he's doing I believe to make sure
that everybody understands down here
what needs to happen he's closed our
bars and restaurants making sure that
we're keeping in track with what the
federal guidelines are but we are seeing
it just like everywhere else and there's
certain hot spots that have seemed to
pop up but at over 1300 we have 470 are
over 400 hospitalized now right now the
curve seems to be slowing just like what
we have seen hopefully that will
continue but everybody's taking it
seriously one of the issues we're
dealing with here is of course it's
coming harvest season we're making sure
our workers are able to get our
supply out our truck drivers to get that
out to the store so it's Georgia is
coping like the risk but we're gonna
make it and we're gonna going to see
this through because you know at the end
of the day is that we're all in this
together and we need to take care of
each other during this time as well that
is so well put we got to take care of
each other and that's one of the things
that has brought us all together but at
the same time at the same time
congressman and you're on the Judiciary
Committee it sounds like the Department
of Justice is looking at people who
purposefully infect others and so here's
a quote from the Department of Justice
coronavirus appears to meet the
statutory definition of biological agent
threats or attempts to use kovat 19 as a
weapon against Americans will not be
tolerated so it sounds like people could
actually be charged if they infect
others knowingly congressman I think
it's a great to see the whole government
approach going on right now the
Department of Justice is making it very
clear if you want to do something or if
you want to inflict harm or
psychological harm or even physical harm
on someone with this virus that they're
going to be taken seriously I mean I've
heard reports of people you know
jokingly saying that they're coughing on
people and I have the virus and they
don't that causes a fear right now that
is unwarranted and I think the
Department of Justice is making it very
clear if you want to do something like
this that hurts the American people
you're going to be in trouble
congressman the other big story there
we'll discuss throughout this three
hours and throughout the day is the
president really itching to lift with
the economic sanctions and the deadlock
on the economy in sections that don't be
severely infected
has there been legitimate talk
bipartisan talk about how to start
opening up the economy again I think the
biggest starting of opening the economy
is this bill and getting the relief aid
to the folks who need it first I think
this has always been the president a
great job of doing a two-pronged
approach number one looking out for the
health and safety of Americans and
making sure we take care of doing social
distancing doing the things that need to
be done to keep the spread down and at
the same time looking with an eye toward
knowing that we're going to come out of
this and that the economy needs to be in
a shape where you can recover and
recover quickly so I think this is
exactly the conversations that are being
had in this bill is the first step along
with the health and safety precautions
are being put
by the president in his team all right
thank you yeah thank you so much for
being with us we appreciate it
good luck thank y'all have a great day
you're welcome you too